sciences bonjour et bienvenue dans
l'épisode musical de ce top year partout
des indices de notre évolution nous
entoure dispersés dans notre quotidien
laissez-nous vous les montrer à travers
une journée pas tout à fait comme les
autres et en chansons le matin au réveil
toujours la même question est ce que je
me lève peut-être oui d'autres non
cette question si vous la posez c'est
grâce à votre cerveau dominé manucure
coupage donc des choses que vous ne
feriez pas si vous aviez des sabots ou
des griffes au bruit des doigts mes
beaux parents je te places et les ont
qui sont au courant de voix primates
tâche facile de s'entretenir du sultan
se plaire mais vous avez toujours le
super de téton de mammifères oui parce
que va-t-il faire ça vient d'eux mêmes
à l'été nos petits chefs a recommencé la
dans la musique est bonne sur la route
du boulot secouer la tête pour un petit
les poissons n'ont pas d'iphone 4 n'ont
pas de coût comme les tétrapodes le
travail c'est pas marrant direction la
salle de gym
l'exercice est vivifiant mais attention
ghana l'afrique
les méduses et les mouches ne seront pas
de bagad karaez muscle s'il y en a que
chez nous et les
est-ce que ça va monsieur j'ai le bras
quoi j'habite à chad dawson bougez vous
avez mal c'est un animal avec le choix
via le sommeil il est temps d'aller se
coucher
attention à la marche n'allez donc pas
vous tue sans savon perdriel à vis une
vie qui était ce nous réunit des
microbes jusqu'au paiement des
tétrapodes ce stade science est finie
merci de l'avoir suivi si vous avez
apprécié n'est il pas partager